how many of you honestly when you're  thinking about doing something  vulnerable or saying something  vulnerable  thank God vulnerability is weakness this  is weakness how many of you think of  vulnerability and weakness synonymously  the majority of people and that myth  is profoundly dangerous I Define  vulnerability as  emotional risk  exposure uncertainty  it fuels our daily lives and I've come  to the belief this is my 12th year doing  this research  that vulnerability is our most accurate  measurement of courage to be vulnerable  to let ourselves be seen to be honest if  we're going to find our way back to each  other  vulnerability is going to be that path